Hello Freak bitches.
J London.
Oh,
Jay Jay London,
J London man.
He's a funny dude,
man.
Jay's funny man.
But he's a boy.
You talking about a guy who's a mess.
Oh,
he's crazy.
We ain't.
London was selling American flags after nine slash 11.
That's what he's doing for a living.
And uh,
I worked with them.
The first Gig I ever did on television in 1992,
I want to say two or three.
I did standup spotlight in New York and it was with me,
me and Jay London and a couple other people and Jay and I were friends,
you know,
from the New York comedy scene and then he just kinda like,
faded away and then he came to La and in 2001 he was like basically like almost
homeless.
Yeah.
Before you did less calm.
Like he was the only guy who stood in line on last comic and made it to the
finals of the show.
Wow.
So he went through the whole line.
You went through the whole addition.
Wait outside.
But I'll get my best j London moment.
We were,
uh,
we were in the house and it was a game,
have fraud had called it 10.
I don't know if you ever heard of this,
but there's a group of people and you start telling facts about your stuff's
self,
starting from the most innocuous thing.
That's number 10.
Like I might say,
you know,
my name's Alonzo,
I'm from New York City,
you know,
and you go around that number nine,
you,
you know,
uh,
I had my first girlfriend at 18 or whatever,
you know what I mean,
like you go number six j Dot j Dot London.
Sometimes I get mad at myself and I ripped pubic hairs out with pliers and I was
like,
that's your fucking six.
Because I had to go after him.
I was like,
that's number six.
What the fuck do I have like six?
And he was serious,
absolutely,
absolutely mad at himself.
Like,
what is your,
what is,
no,
I don't think we got to number two.
What is the amount of himself for,
who knows,
who knows?
Jay,
Jay's a sweetheart.
But,
uh,
but definitely a tortured soul.
There are a lot of demons.
It was,
it was fascinating watching him become famous because knowing him as long as I
knew him and then for us for a small window of like a year or so after last
comic standing,
he was really well known.
No,
absolutely.
People loved him.
Yeah.
We were at the store.
People would love him.
He would.
People come up to him at the store and they'll go,
can I get a picture with you?
And he'd be like me,
you want a picture with me?
Like he was like genuinely confused.
Yeah.
He never figured it out.
He was a guy who needed someone to take care of them.
You need a manager?
Yeah.
He needed a man in here that would,
uh,
handle and take care of him,
which he didn't book them.
Just get them booked.
I mean,
it's just like having him manage his career on his own.
Did he ever have a manager?
He was with a battery briefly.
Exactly.
Did he ever have a manager that.
No.
Yeah,
no,
he didn't.
We,
we,
we toured with them for awhile.
Me,
him and Gary Goldman toward for about six months.
Really?
And I'm being,
Goldman would call it London itis where you just get tired of Jay,
like you love him,
but man,
I can't do it anymore,
you know?
But he needed,
he needed somebody to help him.
It was fucked up because it was one of those cases where if somebody worked with
him,
he could have sustained it.
You know,
he's,
he's a guy who could just come in and do 10 minute guest spots forever and
people would love it.
Well,
he opened up for Louis recently in La at the comedy store when Louis was warming
up for his standup special.
Yeah.
That he filmed there and he was really funny,
man.
He's got some great one line.
He's got some killer one.
My girlfriend had crabs.
I bought a fishnet stocking.
I'll be over here.
And he was like,
move the microphone.
When he went on a joke didn't go well.
He's the only guy I know who could honestly do the same joke twice in one set
because he forgot and the crowd would laugh because everyone knew,
like he honestly forgot.
He's already told that joke.
Oh yeah.
Well,
that's Dr Davidson from the UFC is the one who connected me with the people,
but dude,
they,
they've done a bunch of people now.
Bunch of UFC people have staggering results.
Yeah.
You're saying Roy Nelson did his knee or Daniel cormier is knee stem cells.
Either of those guys at Ak.
I would just do every joint.
Even if there's no problem,
I'd be like if you were the coach,
you back,
just get in there and just do it.
That's what Ludwig did.
Pretty applicable.
Preemptively got both shoulders done.
I think he did his hips too.
Dude.
I can't imagine the fuck.
He's such a savage and to hold knits for somebody like,
like him.
Like winkeljohn should do that too.
Like you beat the fuck out of yourself.
Brandon Gibson,
all those guys.
You professional holder,
you need to do that.
That's worse than fighting.
Yeah.
For,
for your shoulder.
Don't health.
That's horrible.
Especially if you're holding mitts for some fucking John Jones.
Come on.
Well Jon Jones hits hard,
but like imagine like,
like travis or Travis Browne,
allister,
allister.
Especially allister when he was on this.
I don't know if that's true or not.
I believe it's true.
I believe it was proven
so dumb that drug shit fucking stupid.
You know,
when I was in high school had to write a paper and the paper that I wrote was
that you should legalize every drug and and I was all the kind of thing,
a 13 year old,
right?
I was all hyped up on,
on,
on Nwa Gangsta rap and I was like,
how in the fuck did easy Egan oozy?
Like he doesn't look like anybody that should have Uzi.
That's true is because he can sell and the black market is the only thing that
makes crime.
I'm like,
why do we have a black if they want to.
But that's the thing is like everybody is all fucking excited about marijuana
being you all plots.
Everybody's a fucking pussy.
You're out there like,
oh look at wic and smoke a joint on CNN.
Well guess what?
You still got fucking 500,000 guys that are locked up.
You should be protesting that every fucking day of pop.
Really actually legal like in those states.
They should just be letting dudes out by the fucking dozens every minute.
That is true.
If you were in Colorado and you're in jail,
I'd be like,
what in the fuck?
What the fuck?
And then how many of those guys are in there?
And then they fucking catch a real case in there because now you've got to fight
or you're a a fuck.
That's horrible.
That does happen.
All that shit should be legal.
The only thing that,
and people are like,
well,
they just tax it.
Everybody's like they just tax to the government.
But that's on the idea that the government gives a fuck the government.
I mean,
it makes more money.
It's not like if I can tax you who wants to buy weed?
I wanted,
how do I tax everybody?
I make them all scared and then I am prison guys for this illegality.
And then I can get the public dollars because look,
it.
Isn't it scary that we got these black and Mexican guys that are selling dope
and we need to put them somewhere.
My stepdad and his,
uh,
his um,
he had a business partner.
And architectural firm and they beat each other up one day.
Should it be like he came home,
he had a black eye and he was in his forties and I was a kid.
I was like,
what?
First of all,
I was like,
I was fighting back down to zero skills like this.
Like what did this fight look like between.
Because I knew as basic as that dead worse.
What is like he's a good guy,
he's a bad person.
But I knew the guy fought with two.
I'm like,
that's even more ridiculous that that guy gave you a black eye because that has
to be thinking.
I'm mad though.
They missed so bad.
Well it was a very complicated situation where they had a government contracts
and then the government lost money.
Like there was like a,
there was a recession and during the recession they cancel a lot of their
contracts.
So these guys,
they put all this time and work and effort into these projects and the projects
were pulled out from under them and all their investment was done super fucked.
It was really bad.
And you know,
they all,
I'm sure there was a lot of blame on both sides and who knows what the fuck
happened.
But it's weird when you see someone come home,
your Stepdad got Scott are black.
I want what are
like if I was pretty sharp but be like,
for sure.
Keep your hands up next time for sure.
Don't let them get that close to you.
Talk Shit to each other.
Get in a fight.
When I was 12,
I'm not making this up a whatever.
Fucking cars.
Right?
My Dad pulls in front of him.
He pulls it from my dad.
He gets out and my dad goes,
you want to fucking go?
My Dad's like,
oh no,
like an old school Irish boxer.
I remember being like 10 or 11 being like,
ah,
fuck man.
See the problem with that is Nick Diaz can actually fight like that.
Oh my dad breaks off this dude that Sun was about to throw him off the side of
the highway.
No leather jacket.
Did Not fuck around when a guy stands out like that.
So that's doing the old school boxing.
One of two things can happen.
He's trying to scare you off or he's so good with his hands.
He just Kinda roll actually.
Like,
what's up dude?
You want some?
Yeah,
man.
It was weird.
That situation.
I'll tell you why.
For reals,
man.
I remember my dad got in the car.
I'm like,
God dammit.
And then my brother gets out,
kicks getting the balls from behind.
I was probably 12 at the time.
He's as Christ brother kicked a grown man and throw him in the balls,
but that's when it gets really dangerous because that kid gets involved.
Father becomes like super violent.
Little Brown was doing what was crying in the backseat.
How old were you?
Probably like 10 or 11 in the back seat.
Can't be trusted if shit goes down.